ja ich würde hier vor allen dingen die
impfquote mehr anschauen bei den über
50-jährigen über 60 m in
dänemark ungefähr 89 90 prozent aber
etwas darüber jetzt in den letzten tagen
konnte er ins land
die haben alle impfquoten in dieser
altersgruppe zwischen 85 und 90 prozent
in deutschland liegt da immer noch bei
84 prozent also da muss man tatsächlich
noch mehr machen denn genau dort sind ja
die 99 prozent der todesfälle gewesen in
der vergangenheit bei den über 50 hin
und die diskussion dass man jetzt
generell im sport braucht bei allen
gewachsen erwachsen geht eigentlich
wieder an der realität vorbei an der
wichtigkeit die älteren zu impfen 50
prozent der todesfälle waren bei den
900.000 wir sagen sie meine zahl der
steuer ab wann haben man sieht es bei
uns so dann aus wie in dänemark müssen
wir da müssen wir dann noch warten also
ich würde denken check nummer eins
altenpflegeheime die impfrate das beste
was man machen kann auf jeden fall dann
bei den 3,3 millionen ungefähr 60 hier
in die noch nicht geimpft sind da
müssten die hälfte noch geimpft sein und
dann musste man den leuten auch
irgendwann mal sagen jetzt haben
allerdings angebot gehabt zur normalität
zurück wir können nicht ewig auf alle
die wirklich jetzt nur keinen
interesse haben aber eben verrückt sich
nehmen aber das gebiet nach 1 vor der
lage wenn die realität denen wollen aus
den intensivstationen dann sehen sie
dort
deutschlandweit eigentlich das den
intensivstationen weit über drei viertel
der personen die dort ihr kriegen
übergewichtig mit migrationshintergrund
wo kommen aus sozial schwachen regionen
das sind die leute die eigentlich nicht
das impfangebot ab gerät haben sondern
die das dings angebot noch nicht
wahrgenommen haben da so die entweder
aus sprachlichen gründen oder aus
sozialen gründen aus ökonomischen
gründen sich haben noch nicht impfen
lassen oder noch nichts von der info
oder bedeutung der erkrankung gehört
haben
[Musik]